amazon everything's gone what i'm saying
to you is is that when i start the
podcast
have you started it now no i wouldn't no
okay because he's gonna do the countdown
so don't say anything until i say your
name
cause i gotta say welcome this and that
and all that stuff do you but it annoys
me in the comedy world
you know that you sang to me don't say
anything
basically is saying say something you
have to you okay
i know in the comedy world that that's
real
but this is not the comedy world
but it literally is it literally isn't
it literally isn't and the thing is is
that
i'm being obvious
it's actually the only thing this is no
no no no no
this is not anything else all right all
right george you're this close to
getting kicked out of the room all right
i'm being [ __ ] real dude i won't i
won't [ __ ] i want you right now
you're really pissing me off by cackling
like that like a hyena all right and you
two gilbert sorry i'm being real all
right and this is really pissing me off
right now dude
i promise i
all right i'm telling you right now if
you even if i hear a [ __ ] breath out
of you
right before i introduce your name yeah
i will literally shut it down i don't
give a [ __ ] because we have this is a
backlogged one anyway this doesn't come
out for two weeks i'll get correct
forgive somebody else to [ __ ] die
i'll i'll get ali wong or something to
do it all right so what i'm saying to
you right now you're gonna threaten me
with [ __ ] ally wong no no don't i'm
just kidding it's a joke all right go so
all right thank you five
four
three
two
one a beautiful day
it really is to meet yeah yeah
it's you it's a beautiful day
it really is to me
yeah yeah
walking down the path
seeing the flower
seeing the bodies fly on my head
walking down
[Music]
welcome to another episode
one more time
oh my god what was the inspiration
i just made it it was so good i love it
it's a hit it's a [ __ ] hit
oh my god that was a song called i wrote
just now called walking down this tree
with my friends
listen guys um welcome to another
episode of tiger belly um
it's been a really interesting week for
me um
great stuff interesting stuff
shakespearean stuff
um we you know we did a
podcast last week was it a patreon
where i almost killed everyone in the
room
i went to a red zone
i'm not apologizing for it because you
guys deserve that
so that was a new for you
in your face
and i'm gonna tell you right now [ __ ]
that you almost got me in the red zone
again
and i'm about to shut this [ __ ] thing
down because i hear cackling that i
don't i don't even know who that is
now you know what now now i'm going to
sing the song again
welcome to tiger belly by the way
welcome to tiger belly we've got kalila
in the room we got george i mean
i'm sorry
i swear to [ __ ] god for a split
second i forgot your name i know you did
gilbert did you say gabriel gilbert
thank you so much thank you let's start
over we got kalila gilbert welcome to
tiger belly thank you
george
beautiful bryce oh wow
and we have a [ __ ] guest tonight um
he literally is um one of my favorites
um
the ugly king of the east
the east yeah
he's a red nut uh that's what i call him
red nut
he's got like uh
some freckles i call him visual aids
oh looks like disease
um
[Music]
he's so racist he talks about chinese
people
all the time right yeah when he has for
a while dude chinese eyes
yeah
there he goes there we go
um he's been on many many tv shows he
was on a very successful tv show called
mixology
it was a hit
he got cancelled before it's time really
mixology
google it dude it's like a good show
it's one of the ones
and um he's also
one of the he's one of the ones that you
have to not watch or watch
either way
he's also
the star of many different things like
the um
what was that one with the um
with the
the room but the other one
the room they made the remake with the
uh
franco disaster artist disaster artist
he was a big star in that
you know he had a monologue in there
that was like unbelievable anyway um
but he's also the star of i'm dying up
here which is a showtime show bought the
comedy store a very good show very good
show he has his own podcast called
whiskey ginger uh-huh
and uh
yeah yeah yeah
his name is andy santino give him a
round of applause everybody
welcome now you can
talk what's the matter what's the matter
yeah go ahead breathe breathe through it
it's a pleasure to be here
thank you thank you so much for having
me on didn't know you're going to really
appreciate i know you're going to be on
today you also don't have a single
freckle yeah i don't have any uh bobby
just uh makes up stuff to make him sound
funny and sweet bobby you gave me a bad
intro for the first time in our
friendship
what do you mean
mixology talk about my cancelled tv show
can i just say this the room the
disaster is a movie i literally got cut
out of
entirely yeah
i'm dying up here yeah my show that
literally just got canceled yeah
okay can i say this though no yeah no
i'll tell you why go ahead cause it's
your show this is your room it's your
girl it's your crew i get it your mics
your camera on a vacuum i get it
oh you misunderstood me friend oh no i
got it yeah oh my god that song what
that song i sang yeah before right right
was about you
by me and you walking down the street
yes okay all right i take it all back
oh
in my head i saw you skipping down the
street with like a bag of swedish fish
that's what it looks like
just like popping them in your mouth
yeah yeah happy together
[Music]
this guy looks like an actor to you wait
warren beatty
which actor which actor does he look
like oh he's in america right now but a
korean actor
oh yeah daniel day kim
oh my god
mama
there's no [ __ ] way she thinks i'm
ugly no you are not like yeah you're not
like all right
but do you think he's handsome or ugly
handsome oh really yeah when i thought
he's a korean he's a very hands-on very
happy but then when he found out he was
filipino he became less handsome no no
no i said he has some korean face yeah
yeah but filipino eyes
and some spanish too you know oh yeah
because i thought this
was spanish oh yeah
yeah yeah she's a tauren you know yeah
don't you love kala how what would i say
yes yeah yeah
i'm gonna be in trouble
[Laughter]
she's great she's great i told her too
you love her you know
right we talk in swimming pool whole my
life to her i know like about one hour
i think she said you tucked her ear off
[Laughter]
we went to downtown l.a today yes we
went to santee alley yeah and we found
the
clothing store we found the clothing
store
she knows you i know the guy at the
clothing store knows you what is the
store who the guy of the clothing store
we went to school
yeah and he told the other guy you know
that's a baby you know
who and he goes
oh yeah you know oh yeah sure
everybody knows you oh
no don't say
when's the last time you were in korea
mom
ah 40 years ago oh [ __ ] but i made every
10 years i make
renew my uh
passport passport maybe someday i'll go
no we will bring you there i think this
year i think whole family should go
together okay and because otherwise i
don't have any place to stay yeah you
know
now how have you
it's my day today you say i don't have
to talk you don't have to talk you said
but you ask me questions i know i mean
can you put your mouth to the mic though
yes thank you yes no you don't have to
say anything but um but you ask me
you're gonna have to answer oh okay yeah
yeah don't answer
[Laughter]
but um
i didn't know i was gonna ask her what i
was gonna ask don't ask about whatever
down there don't do this oh about what
the vagina yeah
but you know what mom
you know when i you know i when i got
sober
i was had a drug addiction in high
school of course and then when i got
brought to you to rehearse i know you
did
and i remember um
saying to myself
i'm just gonna have a relationship with
my parents while they tell i tell them
everything
yeah right so i've you know remember i
used to go get prostitutes i used to
tell you
i don't do that
i know but i used to tell you everything
that is very uncomfortable to hear from
my son's mouth oh it is yeah oh don't
tell me details oh the details yeah no
so i just i did that then
yeah okay you're a man
here we go
well there we go yeah all the man's
doing this all the man's doing yeah all
men of animals you know
including my husband great husband i
have to include in him so nobody say bad
things for me yeah yeah yeah would you
say mom that um george him
is the ugliest guy in the room
you
why george
that backfired what the heck
why
you know what george you know he starts
to sit there and do
this guy
all right so that's steven's friend
right
best friend
it's an alliance you have no idea who
you're in bed with right now that's okay
it's okay i don't care uh stone so i
come to i fly into um yeah yeah
our dad's dying right would you say that
he's getting sick
i wouldn't say dying but you know he's
sick he's stable right now so let me ask
you a question is it appropriate
when your dad's sick
and you're in their house
to look at your brother and go
bob
can we go to walmart to get pringles
let me ask you something is it
appropriate
um
yes and no okay so
why why did you want me to get pringles
well i was so bored no no no you okay i
was bored
you know
girl girlfriend's not around yeah yeah
um i was sick of masturbating
with just uh vaseline
because i was just masturbating with uh
vaseline and i would you know paper
towel yeah
yeah okay and so i looked up on um
youtube or google um
well i looked this up i said i looked up
homemade uh pocket [ __ ]
oh you did arson craft during your yeah
definitely
so what i found out is you could take
simple household supplies
and make uh
kind of like a fifi like a just a pocket
tell me how from beginning to end it
works good surprisingly how does it
become a vacuum though i'll show you i
want me to we'll break it down
i won't show you but we'll break it down
yeah break it down first
let me just say this before anything
okay what happened that night well i'll
tell you what okay
okay you go bob
check this out would you think you're
gonna see like
you know a cool soccer footage of
something or
you know i mean or a fail you know
you don't think you're gonna see an
instructional manual on how to make a
[ __ ] homemade pocket [ __ ]
no they do so we saw we saw it
and then what did we see
um so what you need is uh two sponges
what kind soft or the scrub part or the
soft ones yeah yeah the cleaning right
yeah the cleaning sponges they sell four
packs at walmart yeah um
rubber bands
and then simple just like plastic uh
like grocery store uh you know like the
bags to stuff it in the pringles
plastic bags yeah just regular plastic
bags
you forgot the most important part oh
latex gloves there we go
the vagina that's the vagina that's your
vagina so you align it so what happens
is um
well we were at walmart and i we bought
two pringles and what would stop this or
something all right okay
this is something that i would never do
on my own
okay yeah i was like a brother it's
something that that's not a brother
that's not bonding even
all right well they're not [ __ ]
bonding it was fun dude it was fun it
wasn't good
it was
fun because it was fun
of
i had to do it separately yeah yeah
she's like dude just yeah you do you get
everything
i'll meet you i'll get you over here
so he has two um pringles
you know
what do you call them cups cans right
yeah that's one flavor uh i think i got
sour cr the onion yeah and then just the
normal there was like a new bread yeah
yeah the brown salt
and also um
we it went to waste because we didn't
even eat the paper no we we actually
walked outside of walmart looked around
and then
and then i just i just dumped them you
guys couldn't wait till you got home no
no
he was afraid his main fear was
like my mom discovering well here okay
so here's one so
so what you do is this okay did i say
rubber bands yeah yeah yeah you just
rubber pants
what you do is you take the two sponges
okay
you take the glove
okay so you sandwich the two stumps of
sponges
on the glove
no
no no you the the two sponges are like
this yeah and then the glove goes in the
middle yeah you sandwich it
yeah yeah yeah that's what i [ __ ]
said
so what's touching your penis has to be
the glove right yes yes yeah because
it's a and the inside of the of the
sponges the sponge so the glove opening
right you you wrap it yeah right so you
sandwich it but then you wrap
it around the um the two sponges yeah so
it holds in place
and then outside
um outside the pringles the top of it
and then you just rubber band it so it
stays in place
okay so it kind of like it just uh does
that kind of
motion yeah yeah yeah and then um you
have two we had a little arts and crafts
sessions upstairs did you try it or did
you try it mine felt great you got one
too you made one too yeah there's two
pieces
broke
mine's mine broke because
no it's not that i did too aggressively
yeah yeah yeah i mean he got mad because
mine i got the pink sponges and mine
looked more like a real yeah and i got a
green one
avatar
we forgot the lotion we bought we'll
forget the lunch [ __ ] the lotion okay
what i found is that you have to kind of
rubber band
the top that like the top entrance part
yeah really tight because mine blew
busted open i don't understand how the
rubber band works what do you mean okay
if you're lining it you're lining the
inside of the can with a sponge and then
inside of that is the glove right where
does the rubber band actually go well
this is bob discovered this he modified
also bobby
the one that's been going on no no no no
no the next night the next night he goes
dude i got it
he's
yeah so he modified it so before we even
put it in the pringles can he uh rubber
band
it all together yeah
the sponges is um the sponges with the
latex gloves so it sticks together so
it's a tighter vagina because if you
don't put the rubber band around there
then imagine it's like your dick will
open it up and it just becomes like
that's it you know poor [ __ ]
poor [ __ ]
yeah yeah
but like so i i put it you know i put
tightened it it tightened it yeah a
second time just to see babe don't get
angry this is amazing
yeah it's pretty cool my theory works i
kind of want you guys to make it i know
we should actually make brian yeah dude
the thing is is this it's easy to make
it the first night
and i hid mine during the day
my brother just leaves it out i go what
if mom walks up there no i hid it like
on the side of the bed and oh you did
hide yeah i thought like you left it out
no way
no oh yeah yeah no so you guys each have
your little canned [ __ ]
and then who tries it first you or him
we didn't do this in the room same room
i know but like what are you like
brother let's do it together
at what point did you guys convene and
then say hey like did it work for you
the next morning or the next day the
next day
dude
good morning yeah no you say you you
don't talk about it right when you wake
up yeah no no no no you have coffee yeah
lately later later like a couple hours
later
awkwardly i turned to him i go did you
do it mm-hmm because yeah it works so
good bob mm-hmm it got mine busted open
so yeah well this is my trick is i don't
know if you
try i don't know
well it was like my um my style was um i
didn't use
um i didn't use lotion
vaseline
so i took vaseline you didn't tell me
about that i didn't no see that worked
that's why you should tell me that i
thought i did did you go dry baby no we
brought jergens
yeah we bought like
five or six different kinds so my
question is is this a one-time used
pocket [ __ ] or do you nut inside and
how do you clean it oh you just take the
latex glove out and then discard it oh
so you can you can you can make one it
was a 50
glove package yeah we bought a 50 pound
[ __ ] yeah
we could have made 50 if we wanted to
yeah yeah if we wanted to yeah yeah but
anyway um we did that while my dad was
downstairs dying god
jesus guys you know so that's a weird
way to put it though yeah yeah yeah but
that's the thing i hear that sadness
does cause it looks like korean oh he
did you [ __ ] somebody else to make him
no who'd you [ __ ] god god did you [ __ ]
god you [ __ ] up god did the full moon
oh you did for you yeah
um
let's start
what's the matter no don't say god don't
say god no
adam did it
all right right ryan hey you should
never [ __ ] god huh no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no do you think god
has a culture
yes you think god has a people like a
god oh we're like god yeah so he's like
us yeah like him so you think god has a
penis everything everything even
but even a butthole why would he need a
butthole no everything like us why did
he make like in his image in his image
oh he missed yeah that's what it says in
the bible like the image i don't read
the bible you've never read it
you haven't read that part
about that chapter in that chapter i
thought you know we all look the same
right but um you've never tried to write
read the bible
i know more than you do
i'm pretty sure you do like what do you
know like creation
and and what and uh wrist
everyone knows that mom i know about
666. what does that do
why does she point to you
he likes me yeah yeah well well if i was
born and had 666 on my head
what would you have done would you would
abort it no no no no no i'm going to let
your hair grow
nobody can see no one can see it right
hide from it right right right
so if i was born with 666 on my head you
would not show me to anybody and just
let the hair grow yeah a little girl
right but you know but you would know
that i was
six to six yeah a demon
or the devil then maybe i'm demon ah
right right right right come on what if
he lit he lit the neighbor's house on
fire when he if like it say at four
years old
oh no he can do that
i'm gonna discipline him you would
discipline me yeah
would you turn me in
would you tell the cops the police that
he blew the neighbor's house on fire no
i gotta just you know
put out hot in a fire and yeah never
turn him in there put it out just put
bug you would put it out yourself yeah
oh water you know right yeah murder you
wouldn't turn me in huh uh maybe parents
maybe hide you know you would hide oh
you would hide no i hide you oh you
would hide me yeah so if i killed like
40 black kids no why did i say black kid
reset that killed what okay sorry
if i sold it
if i killed it don't say colors here
all right
no races no race here yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah we are
asian i think everyone there's also this
really fat guy in a canoe that hates me
a lot why on instagram why i don't know
he's like yeah it might be from whittier
actually he's a really really fat guy in
a canoe and he's always like his
pictures he's probably like 400 pounds
he he might be like filipino or asian
but all his pictures is just of him and
his can like
fat body on a canoe that i'm surprised
hasn't sunk and like he just fishes it's
weird who hates you here's another thing
is that when i posted
this one right
the picture oh i was there you did that
in arizona right but then there was a
guy on here that commented i think it's
still there
that's disgusting why would you hire a
model that poor model you may have to
touch your
penis and then some guy said that's his
girlfriend he goes no it's not yeah he's
just a comedian yeah that you know what
right and then i was just i'm reading it
going what yeah
you know what it is
to the outside world or other single men
yeah they can't
co they can't agree with that or even
that can't enter in their mind that a
person that looks like you wait wait
wait wait stop
no
stop there
just stop there yeah i get what you're
saying yeah what the [ __ ] do you mean
no but i know you said a person that
looks like you no just your vibe or just
no no no no no no no you went from
it's not just my [ __ ] no no physical
presence it's my [ __ ] energy no it's
just your whole being
what so you think everything
to them they can't even believe there's
no way it's like an alternative why why
why i don't know yeah there's something
about you they can't accept you being
with a someone like that that's like a
lack of exposure it's like that guy you
told me in tempe bob went to the atm
right and
you're you guys are standing together
and then there's like a frat dude
look and then he looked at you guys
together and he couldn't believe it and
he was like [ __ ] pissed
yeah but to me it's like but to me it
doesn't it's not i don't you know first
of all i don't look at kalila like i
she's like family now
yeah i'm so unfuckable no that's not
what i mean no but you know what i mean
you'd rather [ __ ] a pringles cam than me
[Laughter]
there it is yeah there it is your
brother is regressing
did he tell you about what happened over
the weekend no i would like to know no
what is you're going to say what
happened this does anyone know what
happened over the weekend does it okay
what are you going to say before we even
get up i might stop the biggest thing
all right well i'm stopping you
what that does has no
business in in this podcast anymore i
feel like it's my right to tell this
story it's my story to tell guess why
what you guys because i had to [ __ ]
put your poop in a doggy bag didn't i
whoa
it's my story now as us
if i have to do the cleanup it's my
story to tell
i have to know the story now please tell
me
tell us bobby please tell your story
you're telling me
so i get a phone call i get a phone call
he's coming home from from warner
brothers and i get a frantic phone call
he's like
that's not something's so bad
oh yeah he went to terrorists mexicans
which is great food
no there's a new one on it
anyway and i get a phone call and he's
like babe something really bad just
happened in my head the first thing i
was like oh my god he's finally run over
somebody
and like that's what happened because of
his driving yeah
dude his driving's insane yeah so then i
was like [ __ ] what happened
and he's like i need help i'm downstairs
in the garage and there's poo everywhere
[Music]
and i'm like how is there poo everywhere
it turns out that he was on the freeway
on route to come home
stuck in traffic
couldn't make it out of the exit pulled
over into the side of the freeway
climbed over into the back seat
and took [ __ ] in the back seat
do you like dad
that's something dad
i can't believe it you're just like dad
man that's exactly what dad would do let
me tell you this story
my dad was driving did he describe this
van
because he put uh his merchandise in it
and then he was on some kind of
freelancer highway
and he couldn't stop either but he did
it on a paper plate at least
he did it right on the scene
disgusting man and then he comes he
comes running upstairs
you're a goddamn animal man
you need help bro
and can i tell you what happened
afterwards he's a beast
so he tells
oh he he comes up and i see his butt as
he runs into the bathroom and it's just
diarrhea all over his pants
so then i'm thinking he couldn't even
take his [ __ ] pants off
his [ __ ] it's his health
no we need to talk up no seriously
his pants and then into the car seat and
then i said fine listen to this steve
oh no
and then
and then
i said okay fine i'll take it to the car
wash in the morning but i was like you
know what i'm not going to do it i'm
going to have jenna do it
because you know jenna needs the money
and i so i told her you better give her
500
she came in in a hazmat suit she i swear
to god she came in fully suited up but
then he goes
it was fifty dollars
[Laughter]
dude
it was
50. oh lord and then he said
he said i tried to
i tried to clean it with a spray as best
as i could so jenna should be fine dry
so jenna basically had
but then that's not the worst part on
the way there
on the way there jenna checked the back
seat because she was like something
smells really bad are you sure that he
clean it with spray
and she goes back there and there's two
big turds that kind of just roll have
been rolling around in the back seat it
was camouflaged into this yeah
so she then has to
she then had she calls me she's like oh
my god i don't know what to do but
there's still poo rolling around back
there
and so i she had to pick it up she had
to use her hand she had to raw hand it
i'm worried about his health
there's so much he's going to get a
colonoscopy
there's so much meat
korean barbecue and just meat that
hasn't digested
yeah he's got so much
just stored meat
yeah bulgogi and steak and because he he
eats so good
we need to get him like flushed out okay
let me tell you my point of view okay
okay
so when you told me to clean the car i
went down there all right i cleaned the
driver's seat because when i climbed
back in there was [ __ ] all over the
driver's seat yeah and when i looked
back there right
it looked like
just the
back in the day during vietnam just like
you know
you know just a war zone
there's [ __ ] all over the place and i i
just thought to myself i got fifty
dollars
and she did it thank you jenna but then
i went to the store though
that night
right and the [ __ ] was still back there
the poo yeah and the you know we have a
lot guy at the comedy store
and he walks in the car and he goes
dude
it smells like [ __ ] in here like there
is
right
and he just left my car there the whole
night in one spot he had to maneuver all
the cars around my car they wouldn't
drive it they wouldn't drive it
yeah yeah
so if you don't want people to drive
your car that's a good way to do it you
know i mean and then also on top of it
um
i'll tell you i'll tell you my point of
view on the incident okay yeah so when i
you could have went out let's just
listen listen to what i what now can you
listen to my point of view yeah all
right
so when i was at terrace which is
delicious by the way
i wanted i ordered just a chicken tinga
yeah super nachos no i didn't have super
nachos in a quesadilla i ate it
and i i was i left the restaurant and
then in my head i'm like oh [ __ ]
i
she i ordered her a salad
right so i ran back in i had already
bought it i could you have the salad i
said to go
yeah and as soon as he grabbed i'm like
this food i'd get to get this to kalyala
because my little baby honey is starving
oh he's going to put it on me no i'm not
going to put it on your baby baby honey
but then when i was
walking out of the building this is what
i heard
right that wasn't even a fart that was
my stomach oh damn
that was your stomach yeah yeah that
wasn't even a fart
i farted inside my body
yeah
have you ever done that it just yeah
i've sucked one i've sucked yeah in my
body and a little sweat and i was just
like
what do i do now this is as an adult you
have these questions
should i get in the car and just [ __ ]
drive home
right or should i just go to the
bathroom here what about going to terry
at terry yeah it was in terry still what
did you just go use her back because she
had to do her salad i would why but it
was awesome to get myself i also just
say can i just say this it wasn't fully
like oh i can [ __ ] right now right i
could just feel like brewing up yeah
right for the record baby honey could
have waited i know a whole hour
i know for a salad i know okay so when
you pulled over no
she got it wrong
okay
so i'm not even on the freeway okay i'm
like kind of like where you know where
highland is but this is like five
o'clock it's packed it's packed
right and it won't move and all of a
sudden
i fell apart that's a fart nothing came
out just far no no but it was like you
know how the that was like my opening
act
like my opening act was strong
yeah
and right then i thought the middle act
was gonna go up but no but the headliner
was there
you'd have time to prepare yeah yeah
there's no middle app nowhere it was a
shark no it was boop and then the head
stuck out
right like that out of the hole like
that right felt solid and i go where's
the middle act
yeah yeah i mean a couple more farts
there's no middle act right so he needs
to go up now the headliner
he needs a diarrhea this is making me
even angrier the fact that it wasn't
diarrhea
means that it wasn't that urgent it was
urgent are you out of your mind it was
so urgent and let me just say this right
now did you see the back of my it was a
it was this show this show
it was a variety show oh wow not just
that right it wasn't just stand up it
was
there was water you know i mean there
was like you know i mean some other
thing that imagine it's a combo system
right
so i pull over to a residential area and
there's construction happening on my
right side and there's you know how
those gigantic construction um
trash containers the gigantic ones
i pull right behind there and i jump in
the back seat i pull my pants down and i
s you know all over
okay and the the beginning of it was the
solid part but the end i'm telling you
right now as jesus as my witness
it was a liquid shell
like oh like cirque du soleil yeah a
circle
okay
and i i felt like killing
myself this smell must have been
horrific it was horrific but he still
brought up my salad with a truck full of
[ __ ] in his butt he came home and
there's poo everywhere but he had a
salad at one hand clean dedicated yeah
dedicated you haven't done that ever huh
i've done it all the time she's seen me
poo on houses yeah
on house walls like he will actually
just bend over shoot it like point his
butt at a wall and spray
she saw me do that and on someone's like
gardenias yeah yeah
we need to leave as a doctor uh we gotta
help we gotta fix it maybe maybe not
i mean his health man
you know no i'm serious yeah like you're
being real serious right not being
serious so you let me ask you something
what do you think is going on with me
your diet
is all meat you think i eat all meat no
veggies no
that's interesting
it's potato vegetable yes it is i eat
that too
i'm just saying
you because you have so much money you
make a good living okay you could eat
korean everyone's listening i do okay
thank you
you you could i know crystalia i'll tell
you that you could afford eating out
he could afford eating out all the time
right uh-huh i don't he doesn't go to
like soup plantation
does he
how is slow plantation like the healthy
spot no it's just not it's just veggies
cucumbers tomatoes
you know what i mean veggies what did i
eat yesterday meat
i did eat meatballs
walk us through like we just smoked it
yesterday yeah so yesterday i woke up
and uh your little filipino niece is
staying with us julianna great oh yeah
she's great and um so i took her to
warner brothers and i go let's go to the
smoke houses right next to it and i had
a prime rib so good
damn right you did yeah right but i had
fried zucchini chips
right fried soup he likes fried stuff
yeah but zucchini deep fried like that
it's not healthy sweetie it totally just
eliminates the outer part is unhealthy
but the inner part is healthy no it's
not you've already taken away all like
deep frying it takes away all of the
good stuff oh
anyway then what else did i have then we
had the artichoke the grilled artichoke
that was good this is all at the same
place yeah at the same place
so i had a prime rib and then
garlic bread and then last night i had
bossanova i had a fried
like you know fried chicken but deep
fried deep fried with batter fries
that's my concern is he's you guys are
doing well he's doing well that's the
only thing that could take him down is
his health that's why i don't go out to
eat with you guys anymore
dude we're not gonna eat after this
because i just can't we gotta we gotta
guess i gotta do they text back
yeah i i have an episode i have to text
but i can't afford to to eat as
indulgently as him so i don't go out to
eat with him i just make my own food at
home because that shit's not healthy
could he do the intermittent
intermittent fasting dude you know what
he actually does it because i was doing
that every sunday i was doing it every
sunday i would not eat for 24 hours gil
that's his that's not his problem
because he actually won't eat for 16
hours but in those eight hours he eats
real pure garbage like taco bell i won't
eat 12 hours and i'll eat a fat burger
with fried egg and chili
yeah
then my body goes crazy and then
straight into like a strawberry
shortcake and then i go right to sleep
so that stuff is in my body when i'm
sleeping yeah he actually has a big meal
before sleep yeah
it's not good guys it's not good and um
you know it's very concerning
is he sleeping okay or no no today he
slept at like 10 o'clock in the morning
in the morning yeah
gonna have a 10 o'clock in the call time
tomorrow morning too oh gosh i mean
yeah he's self-sabotaging i i i i you
how do you jesus
i mean do you what time do you go to
sleep um like one two two three what's
better what are you doing oh you're
playing red dead redemption which i want
to talk about okay
great segway
what a great you're a professional oh
go ahead baby
god where are we gonna say that so i
have an alter ego for that i gave my dog
my dog's name's goby but her alter ego
is a stripper named trina michelle right
oh okay
from corpus christi she moved to atlanta
because that's where it's a hub of like
sugaring and being a stripper right
cheetah so i call her trina michelle and
i'm like trina michelle you gotta pack
your [ __ ] bag blah blah and he's in the
room and he's losing his mind because
he's like my daughter is not a stripper
like losing his mind about it so we got
into the discussion of you know what you
would do
if you know your daughter is you know in
1920 and she's like you know what dad
i'm not gonna like stop college i'm
gonna continue but i like being an
exhibitionist i like the acrobatic
nature of it i'm going to be a stripper
and he lost his [ __ ] mind over it
nah
that's my answer
if i have a daughter she ain't going to
be a stripper you're so old school open
your mind
first of all
i want to be able to like if my daughter
is a performance artist i want to
support okay let's suppose this let's
make you guys so we're going to go we're
going to go we're going to go we're
going to go those are a couple my
girlfriend's
my daughter's a stripper you uh we're
all going to go watch your prank no no
no listen let's see her vagina you guys
are gay dads and you adopted me okay
i'm 19 i'm 20. wait wait wait yeah
me and david are gay yeah you're gay
dads and you're adopted so we've watched
beauty and the beast together yes we've
all watched
this yeah can i just say this
then i have to be the bottom
wait you have to be the bottom
[Laughter]
and he has my ankles and he's sucking me
up like that oh yeah
[Laughter]
i'm not just now listen i don't want to
do that but i want to just see if that
would work with the clothes on
to see if you could
i don't think i had the upper body
strength though oh
that's a good excuse
oh
that's
a
lot
like i told you this is the vest hides
everything yeah you have upper body
don't lie i saw you about that new
workout you're on this like new weight
loss thing yeah but that's all legs the
upper body
i'll like
create an apparatus where i have i'm
like
wow you adopted me and i'm gonna tell
you this is my speech to you dad dads
dad and dad um i graduated valedictorian
from
look at his face you know what's so
interesting every time in these
scenarios it's like
this person has to be the highest
pinnacle of human being you know i mean
yeah i'm gonna be the stripper but i
cured cancer like what the [ __ ] does
this happen yeah yeah yeah so can we
just bring it down to real life we're
not validating so we're here let's see
here we are let's play the scene out
then okay so remember david all right
just visualize right
we've been together for
no describe the second scene no we've
been together for 20 years right
we've must have [ __ ] a lot you and i
80 000 times
right such a high number and i see it as
high but you've also never stepped foot
in the strip club because obviously
you're both okay but you and i have
really eaten everything
off each other okay yeah but we love
each other too in this scenario okay
and this is our daughter we love our
daughter all right what's going on with
your face right now because at this
point if that's true i don't give a [ __ ]
what she does
i've eaten ass every day like what the
[ __ ] do i get nobody
yep no but in our private life nobody in
the world knows that in when we close
doors like we're like we we're shirt
talkers yeah right what
no we take takeoff we have button ups we
tuck it into our pants we have belts
we go to where we have briefcases what
are your jobs we go to work i need to
know about the jobs i'm an executive at
um uh enterprise rental
executive
david
david is a what no he's a key maker
he's like a locksmith what in the world
is a key maker
but he has his own business because he
came into my business right right right
years ago
yeah
in the early 80s you know i walked in
you know i was confused
and we met each other anyway so
we have regular we have regular jobs you
guys are thinking too much about the
relationships
let's go back to the stripper please no
no no no i have to i need backstory okay
okay okay okay
i need backstories okay craft wouldn't
build it so um and we met in the early
80s
and obviously we're gay so we can't so
we adopt this beautiful baby okay this
girl and we love it with all our hearts
okay we take it to like disneyland
[Laughter]
we actually created a thing where we you
and i bought a real doll
right yeah we got a real dot and we
filled
the titty with milk
so that she could have real breast milk
oh okay so i could have a mother
experience yeah like we really go out of
the way out of our way quite large and
at night
we tuck our little baby into the little
cradle right and then we go to our room
bobby what happens in the room yeah what
happens we lock the door we lock the
door just in case the baby i don't need
to stop the story because i can already
smell the room and it smells terrible oh
my god the visuals are bringing a smell
it's a four-hour [ __ ] fest
and then the alarm clock goes up we put
on our shirts we tuck in our pants and
bye david
bye sweetie and we go to work
so now we raise this kid
back to school private school
listen private school right
and uh
and
you know and she's the lover alive yeah
and at 19 she comes to us and this is
what she says go ahead
i know i told you guys that i was
planning on going to med school
i still plan on it but i have this side
of me that's just very you know
exhibitionist
i love you know i've been a gymnast my
whole life i love dance i love you we
used to love baby we used to love coming
to you you watched you showed me all
those musicals yeah you remember
sweetie remember i do baby yeah
yeah can i okay
i'm gonna be my own character then yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm a korean
fob now yes
ava carso
yeah
i love your little accent baby oh is
that of course
wonderful
what is this
i really respect you guys but and i have
a lot of respect for my body of course
but i just really
i just really want to be a stripper and
i want to see what that life's about i
want to make extra money
and i think that with my sex appeal and
with my sexual openness stop
sweetie stop
that's fine you can do whatever you want
with your life
but um
i pay for your cell phone oh [ __ ]
we're cutting it off i can pay for that
myself if i start stripping i have a car
yeah
hold on sweetie hey can you go eat my
butthole in the room real quick
[Laughter]
not paying for medical school and um
you're not you're not doing that
why not because we provide you with all
the money that you would need you're
going to medical school you're not doing
that it's about showman
well then become
become a dancer like or i'll take you
can go to class we'll take take you to
class any kind of class that you want if
you want to do a live show but i like
the seediness of the strip club i like
that atmosphere
but then at this point there's nothing i
can do for you baby
go go live your life
and don't call home oh dang okay
can i put my real dad head on yeah okay
for me it would be okay it's a little
unfair for you to spring it up on us
like that out of nowhere you didn't have
a conversation with me about this
previously your favorite father and i
personally think that that's really
offensive and on top of that if you want
to live your life however the hell you
want then you can do it without taking
money from us now if you want to follow
our rules then of course we can support
you in that i will always love you but
you are now a [ __ ] so i understand but
that is what i'm not selling my body for
sex life
object you're going to buddy i just want
to dance i'm telling you you can dance
all you want [ __ ] yeah you could do it
with your clothes what the [ __ ] does
that have to do with it now daddy's
angry yeah because you're just being
guys you could tell daddy daddy i've
seen you guys be a certain way you guys
have been nudists your whole life and
you've not noticed we've closed the door
behind closed doors it doesn't matter
yeah we are cloaked god can't even see
us yeah god can see us by the way by the
way daddy you break my heart i am a good
father i eat ass all day i don't care
at all every time i drink i never share
the cup with you yeah
okay what if what if now and then
but also just in this scenario once a
year we have a special
in this scenario once a year we have a
special night on our
anniversary gill bits comes over wow and
we do it three way hey guys
what that voiceover
hey uncle gil yeah what are you doing
here i'll be honest about the [ __ ] your
day
[Laughter]
okay so what if what if let's say i
didn't want to be a stripper but at 17
i'm like dad you know what i want to
sell my virginity online and i want to
give the money to like the
international i want to give it to
charity [ __ ]
what charity is this
amnesty international get the [ __ ] out
of here
you are going to be sold to the sex
world and also i also kind of just say
this you would never if with us as your
parents you would never even think about
because you'd know us
you would know what our reaction would
be why is our stripper daughter so
stupid i don't understand why you're so
dumb i was adopted you don't know what's
in my dna stupidity do you think that
dripping is it is a genetic i mean a dna
thing i mean i think that there are
people women who are hyper sexual and
really want to perform that way [ __ ]
we're not saying you're not you're a
[ __ ] no
there's an element of showmanship and
being do it in front of your boyfriend
or whatever don't give a [ __ ] what if
she wants to parlay that into a business
down the road where she's listening to
like suburban white women i feel like
this is you
you want to go
i can't even [ __ ] clack my heels
properly
how much money are you making though
um let's say
off the business or me as a stripper no
off the whole business all together
realistically let's say i take home okay
cash okay okay 120k a year of course
then go ahead
that's accordion way money over morals
all right how about this would you
you're a let's say you're really hot
yeah
would you
that's all it is is lap dances and
stripping no it's down the road i really
like the performance aspect of it i want
to parlay it into an
a business where i can teach women in
the suburbs you could strip construct
okay but you can stress
as long as you don't [ __ ]
yes i'm not i'm not into prostitution
or porn
oh no porn i just want to dance daddy
you could dance with your clothes on is
all i'm saying what i'm thinking right
now yeah is that
i just don't like people objectifying
you in that type of way yeah and i think
that if you could use this versus this
it's a lot more impressive you could do
whatever you want behind doors i'm
completely okay with that and i love you
no matter what but if you become a
stripper and we're walking in the
grocery store i might ignore you okay
daddy but i have an argument to that
what if to a certain degree i like being
objectified what if i enjoy that voyer
aspect when people are watching me and
looking at me just be young i don't want
to intellectualize this i want to be a
woman with tits and ass that's moving
around and a man salivating over me it
empowers me that why is it so that's so
unfair that i have a such a dumb
daughter
life is so unfair for us
oh wow
i love you as a partner
don't forget me
okay
i told you to change the boxes
no no no it's not me i often think about
how i would approach it if i had a
daughter like
what would you do yeah i'd be really
torn because i want to empower her and
make her like
[ __ ] god i know you clila there is no
way that you would agree to what look i
know you the only reason that i the
reason why you didn't do it the reason
why you didn't do it because you're you
know your mom swimmer and your mom no my
mom sister i don't think they would i
don't think your mom would sign up for i
look at asa she's at the top of her game
poor she's intelligent she's she's just
the best at what she does love awesome
but dude have you seen her videos but
she enjoys it she had two dicks coming
out of her ears but she loves it i i
mean i'm not
that's
but she's i love
she's been we did our podcast early on
i love her as a person she can she's
family
when she talks about it she's always
been a hyper sexual person and she's
always enjoyed she knew her when she was
a kid i know so how can you take away if
it bothers you but doesn't bother her
why why is it
i think
it's but we're allowed to be bothered by
it though just like you have your own
choice to choose what you want to do i'm
allowed to be bothered by it as well
yeah so i'm glad that you know if my
daughter did talk to me about it that's
dope but once again you sprung it on to
me out of nowhere i could have helped
you out yeah if you wanted to start a
business we could have made money
together now you want to make money by
yourself without your parents [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah i think you're more
looking at it also for the safety aspect
of it being a man and knowing just the
overall seediness of well for me it's
like this uh i grew up with the mom
that's very strong very outspoken and
people respect my mom because of those
aspects guys are [ __ ] dogs
they will only see you for that as smart
as you think that you are doesn't mean
that these guys will see you that way
too yeah so if you are if you want to
command that type of respect and the
same thing goes for men too if a guy's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and all he has is buff
that's all women cms2 it works both ways
the reason why i got sober at 17 okay
wasn't because of the fact that like i
mean i did have like a spiritual
awakening and i was so very desperate
but i also saw my parents and the way
they reacted and how destroyed and hurt
they are
and it's like i
you know i'm very influenced by
how they feel you know about things
and so and i've been very you know
intuitive in that way of like how
they react to my decisions i think that
you're sensitive to them yeah and i
think that by me going i wanted to stand
up and them reaction to that was a
little
that that i could go you know what that
they're delusional but in terms of like
things like
hey
you know
i'm addicted to drugs and and seeing
their reaction
you know i i have to be sensitive to
that as a as a son you know and i hope
that my daughter would be sensitive to
that fact but you're acting as if
you know you're not sensitive to us no i
love you i respect you i just have this
inner desire
yeah but the way you're approaching us
just out of nowhere okay i don't know
where it may be yeah yeah and
left breadcrumbs a little bit
like you just got naked in the kitchen
out of nowhere
that's like of course i knew this one
yeah
you know and then for some reason she's
17 and her lip is like hanging into the
[ __ ] glass
[ __ ] every day cucumber missing
[Laughter]
my kimchi i know i try to make cucumber
kimchi i never can he maybe love me too
much but she you know watch me every
movement i make yeah you were telling me
earlier how even when you would um think
like have a crush on warren beatty
um
oh my god jealous i couldn't watch his
movie oh and elvis presley i couldn't
hear his wait wait so if
he came home from work and you were
watching um a warm baby
i said why he goes you know you don't
like him i don't want to watch his movie
oh but
but you said as you got older he stopped
caring
no it's a i got older like uh 60 years
old
and i asked him do you still jealous of
you know he go no
now at 8 years old man gonna look at so
why should i walk right but when you
were young
i was pretty pretty yeah
prettier than this and now i'm gonna put
it down but i was very sexy and prettier
oh [ __ ] you were sexy and pretty back
then on because daddy liked my side of
my leg
that's what he like you know so he likes
your side leg
wow i've never heard wow because i have
a short dress you know whoa
easy access huh
yeah yeah
to the [ __ ] beautiful yeah don't say
a [ __ ] like okay
[ __ ] i don't like you don't like
[ __ ] no i know you're like you're
like
you used to put soap in steve's house he
was a must because really he said you
know a bad word for him so i put a
little soap i put steam you know stephen
don't tell him
i put he forgot all about it yeah and i
put his mouth and and said if you uh you
know say one more word to young yeah
you're gonna be in trouble right after
that he doesn't do that he was a very
you know strong little boy who was steve
yeah he was
he used to punk you a lot oh yeah when
he were little when i was little yeah
well i don't remember when he gained
weight he never do that again
what do you mean no
what do you mean i think you
no when you get bigger you think i'm fat
no big eyes bigger yeah so you wouldn't
ever say
let's say no one knew who i was and i
was lost and you're describing somebody
to
about me
describing me to somebody would you say
that i was fat no at that time you are
not okay like when you start making
money
you eat too much you know
so success success yeah that's not my
fault that's not my fault i read you're
very skinny yeah i didn't feed you i
know you did it i know it's my fault
yeah i did this to myself oh yeah don't
blame him i'm not going to blame you
he's just not in dna
i'm on my floor yeah you like gummy
candy ma
i don't eat that that's too sweet i i
like you know hard one yeah this is just
like huangos oh my god
he's bigger than that
you think so yeah
so so when you came here in the 6